I'm Nikki today I'm reacting to my very
first eating your feed video before it
was even called eating your feed this
was just like Adam was like you made
this cheesecake I was like okay
and then this video have pop-pop okay so
here we are my best friend Adam and
challenging me to make this jiggly
cheesecake today that has been
popularized in Japan here's the jiggles
there's like a very smooth rounded top
which then I'm gonna brand this is a
good episode
I need to cut this into a circle so let
me see how I can do that
I still don't know how to do this
[Applause]
[Music]
find the Middle's all whoa for real I
lost too much
my growth this is on meeting I was like
what are you doing I don't know because
of the show I've become a lot better at
cooking and baking which is pretty fun
but at this time I was pretty
inexperienced definitely never made
anything like this and that's what I
told Adam I was like I don't even know
if you're gonna have a cheese cake by
the end of this video and he's like
that's fine and I was like okay you
could tell from this video I did not
know what I was doing and who should not
have cut up the butter and the cream
cheese I sent two days like cracking
eggs no lumps no lumps no lumps kinda
lumpy and I don't think it's supposed to
be lumpy so now a [ __ ] ton of egg whites
[Music]
because my yo bro that part was funny
because I remember when like Adam was
editing this episode he was like so
proud of how he cut that together and
then he censored me unnecessarily which
made it funny okay thirteen we did it oh
my god gross I am a racing water whisk
my egg whites so I'm gonna add some
cream of tartar in tartar tartar is it
like tartar sauce I always said it cream
of tartar everybody's face in the room
when after I say that is like tartar
tartar tartar is like a thing in your
teeth or like tartar sauce
I don't like cream of tartar has
anything to do with those two things
no okay left I don't know how much of
this to you
cream of tartar that can help make
stiffer peaks but I feel like all of the
dumb stuff that I said in this episode
the way he would to put the text up I
like to think I have a hand and helping
establish that weird text format because
I said so much demographic as I was said
so hmm pretty stiff to me I think I'm
gonna call it I feel kind of okay about
this everyone is so surprised that this
is what it looked like the first time I
was like yeah I mean she's kidding
so this was the hardest part of getting
out of the pan
[Music]
pretty good oh yeah it tastes like a hot
hot eggs does not taste like cheese wet
is very bad but look at it jiggle it
needs to taste more like cheesecake
why is words it got so much worse
ordinary well but I am gonna change the
taste I'm gonna add more cream cheese
this time a couple more egg yolks
vanilla cuz usually that makes baked
goods tasty and more sugar
[Music]
oops I was so confident at this point
was the first one looked great and I
just needed it to taste a little bit
better but I drastically changed the
recipe and like it didn't even like
cross my mind that it would be like very
different to bake this is a real journey
look to all it is it's just like massive
and like not cooked oh it broke just
like deflated entirely when I slammed it
down still wet tastes more like
cheesecake so the taste is there much
better there was a really big crack in
it
this whole each cheesecake took so long
does terrible cuz I started off so
strong and then everything was falling
apart we're back day two you know here
include me I'm really scared that it
only gets worse from here
we made some at a s'more like cheesecake
and no cracks on top it's so cracked
well I was wearing and I think this it's
that best taste is it Scott we should
have baked different yeah a little wipe
it oh this is my favorite shot not fair
like creep
I don't like cheesecake number four I'm
determined that this will be the last
you're adjusting some measurements less
batter overall we are also low this by
this point this was like the end of the
day this is like 5:00 p.m. and they were
like cool last one and then I destroyed
it it wasn't browning so we turned the
temperature back up and literally within
like I've been literally in the kitchen
and I have someone was like burning and
I go so this is like after hours like
everyone stayed so that I could make
another stupid cheesecake
I think when I started this batch it was
like 5:30 and Adam was like if you want
to stop I'm a burnt one
you can I was like I I can't
it's by far the worst one we have to
keep going came a little bit ago
[Music]
it's tall the ground huh terrible
oh that's nice
I think compared to the video we got the
jiggle down the light bottom but Browns
top-down the no crap brand I didn't
quite good this was fun cuz this was
when I was really first just working on
tasty as like a person on camera like
cooking people were like cheering me on
which was so nice and so many people
wanted the recipe I think it's awesome
like sometimes like to this day people
will like make the Cheesecake and then
like tag me on Instagram and I think
it's really sweet because they like
watch me fail five times and we're like
I can do that so people like seeing us
fail and that's fine I like it - I like
videos like those because he'd make me
seem very funny even if I'm not that
funny people really well she loves
herself I do and I love eating your food
this has been me watching me on a video
about me
[Laughter]
[Music]